[Music]
okay so I'll admit I am sometimes
partial to the odd swear word and I'm
certainly not one to be easily offended
however I currently have a bee in my
bonnet about swearing in particular how
it's become normal for people in the
public eye to drop swear words with
casual ease seemingly not caring who may
be watching whether it's Robbie Williams
bizarrely giving us the finger at the
world cup or Gary Lineker
dropping the F wares repeatedly in his
tweets everyone seems to be out here and
I'm old-school
I don't swear in front of kids
definitely not in front of grandparents
and I'd certainly try to do my best to
avoid doing it on social media
I think swearing makes me look it's had
crude rather than cool and if anything
I'm trying to reduce the amount I do it
so I might be in a snowflake or do I
have a point but it's time for those in
a position of influence to watch their
P's and Q's be sure be sure outside of
here I am doctor potty mouth all right I
can't be stopped I'm a Gordon Ramsay
that look a primary school teacher okay
yeah all right expletives as you might
call them or expressive to me all right
I do swear either swear a lot
do you prefer medium in fact I'll put it
it takes every last second of my
training in the military okay to stop me
especially when I froze on from dropping
f-bombs left right and center absolutely
okay so I don't think that the odd thing
on Twitter or that you know and if you
looked at my Twitter handle I swear I'd
be constructive Mike but when I read my
book okay
it came back alright I did it was
ghostwriter I don't you know there's no
there's not all that and it came back it
was like hi oh dude
no I didn't I did it this way and I had
to insert swear words at appropriate
places otherwise it just wasn't me that
was in that book so if you want to see
the real me which is what social medias
about seeing the real Garrard indica
well drop the old f-bomb
do not move
so don't you so my mom will be watching
this am i mom or laugh gonna count
believe that Michelle has chosen this
topic she knows the eyes and I do and
that is mean I am trying to change
accidentally like it but it's a habit
but on social media etc or on wherever I
just feel uncomfortable because I think
well I don't even know was gonna read
that you put on the show you put on the
resale on social media when you read my
tweets you will see it's the real Mickey
but what I don't feel a need to do I
don't feel a need to say I can say that
was rubbish
it's not a Carolyn it care for example I
read a couple of tweets for bring
everyone else it and so here's an
example in the 80s to get in you effing
be scores again this afternoon not
expect exactly the same because that's
passion and that's believing and that's
saying who you are not getting
politically correct again Sonia myself
you're all wrong on this one with you I
agree with you I also I am like you I
don't know why but I feel uncomfortable
when I see a swear word in writing yeah
then when you write something it makes
it much more powerful than even when you
say it and you can never take writing
back you know once it's on paper or on a
screen it's there you can't take it back
so for me I do think that people in
positions of influence ie
our Twitter in chief should actually be
much more responsible and I don't think
anybody really needs you don't need to
swear on Twitter or anywhere in public
in the same way I think he's actually a
friend
I don't tweet anything like as much as
you I would never ever put that in tweet
but I tell you what to underscore use
because I do swear too much but that's
the product of a newspaper and it's your
media industry where people swear and
I'm not particularly proud of it I do
swear far too much and but they've been
being on the radio and TV you learn to
self-censor so I stop there but the
difference is you could ask the the
person in my life if she if I'm mildly
angry I might get last night was an
effing disaster doubt of it if she sees
the word and it's only happened twice
it's she sees the word spelled out she
knows there's a real big round and she
rings up for her oh my god what's gone
wrong said you're right the power which
I think mr. limiter is lost because it's
too often it's too often I hear what
you're saying
should be something that has such she's
had phrases in the word twice by God she
knows that there's a problem to people
who know me and from I saw that
background it's apparent groom
backgrounds you know it's all the
dressing room background is military but
what Gary came back and said to you or
on Twitter well is is blot me and I
thought that I got yeah okay what did he
say he said to the tiny minority
I like swearing because it adds emphasis
occasionally I don't do it on telly is
obviously you probably don't watch
football to hear what I've got to say
but honest we taking always on following
a few what letters put together to form
the word offends you so what do you
think Rachel well you know Gary tweets
in a personal capacity and it's his
choice to use the words he does and they
may offend some people and I think that
you know I think you had a point when
you called him out on it because he's
got millions and millions as followers
and many children for those Gary Lineker
is he a role model and two boys probably
before you think on that don't you yeah
you do I think Michelle has a point I
just want to say something about Robbie
Williams is flipping the bird because
there wasn't more of a backstory to that
but he got a lot of hate on social media
for doing
the opening ceremony in the world for
the World Cup and people said you know
you're taking blood money Putin's and
this and that and you know you've got no
you know standards you know you're he
did it for nothing and I think that's
why he sung I did it for free and then
he because I think that he was with him
swearing at the end because he was he
was countering the lies that had been
peddled on social media that were doing
his reputation all damage and I think he
was upset he was expressing himself I
want to throw a few new suggestions new
words to use instead of swear words okay
we ready yeah how about fudge nuggets
okay fiddlesticks Great Scott Merlin's
beard Shooks
dad namet holy cow mother schmuck Oh use
that one for you pluck it or even
shitake mushrooms I'll I'm gonna come to
you is that you mum and here are some
other celebrities who've expressed
themselves it's not just mrs. Linacre
and Williams let's take a look at some
others Lily Allen unpopular opinion a
Farraj will be back leading you Kip soon
and they will win a general election
within 5 years unless everyone wakes the
F up Jeremy Clarkson motormouth himself
if'n love Detroit God knows why I
certainly don't and Jess Phillips
apparently this one might have been
suggested for you Rachel tweeted to
someone who called her a tory f off
plain and simple as that yes that's
right so this there's a lot of people
doing this show I'm not offended I don't
see that word the F wedding oh my god
I'm so offended let me sitting there I'm
sorry I'm not like that but what I'm
saying so it's not like I'm offended and
if you'd have seen the reaction that I
got when I was message Carolina care I
never seen like I wish that I'd got some
example against they were calling me the
S word they would see words before we go
we've just got time for this female
reporters have faced sexism in sport for
decades but at this year's World Cup
some have had enough julia gimr aged
reporting for a Brazilian TV channel had
just finished filming in Russia when a
massive of a fan decided to show his
affection for her needless to say she
wasn't having any of it
for standing up for harassed women
everywhere
ms gimr ash you are definitely a
straight talker of the week good totally
right credit to you because there was
commentary done absolutely brilliantly
by I'm afraid I come in which particular
commentator it was for the first ever
World Cup game one of the women on the
panel English female player oh my god I
think this world cuts been a real force
event for people who are picked in Sport
Vitesse box
Vicki sparks well done to you of your
great work that's it for this week but
if you'd like to join in the debate just
search for the pledge on Facebook or
Twitter thanks for watching
[Music]